uh how you doing it I'm so good really
good how are you I'm good
no really I'm not the crack through that
thin layer of hospitality uh let's talk
about Saudi but ignore my problem is
there anything that you yourself can do
really well really fast
uh gee did you see it I just ran around
you're sure yeah yeah I was I was really
happy to see a lot of familiar jim
carrey energy and quirks yeah I was fun
man how much fun I'm wondering if the
energy comes from the same place is it
always did do you find it from the same
place or is it something new for you now
uh you know I think it's always come
from the same place I think everybody
starts out with like a divine spark
inside them and some people hang on to
it and some people beat it to death and
then some people blow it out you know
and I've been lucky I've been able to
stay connected to that kind of a
childlike you know discovery energy you
know and that's what it is that's what's
cool about the characters is that you
know on the video game you don't really
think about it but when you have to act
a character you have to understand where
he comes from you know you have to you
have to work from the ground it's like
the lightning comes from the ground you
know what I mean so it's like you start
with okay where's this guy come from and
I throw through lines in like you know
rub that in my orphan face and whatever
is stuff like that because you know this
is this is genius
combined with neglect and a sense of
absolute worthlessness which is so fun
to play you know because it's just your
value comes from the outside there's
nothing going on in there and when Sun
it comes along he's like the
personification of of pure you know
innocent discovery and fun you know an
electric play you know so I'd say that
Robotnik has a sonic she
hole in his heart I think I think can
never be filled horrible medical
condition yeah
I'm wondering because because this
energy remind me of so much of your your
you know the earlier classics and stuff
like that and we're living through such
an age of you know remakes and reduce
I'm wondering what you think the first
Jim Carrey classic movie to be remade
will be my gosh well they have they've
had made many sequels done without me I
wasn't into it
I don't know gosh I don't know I mean I
think Truman Show is is a is is
something that exists on a micro level
now you know it was that it was kind of
a story about that on a macro level but
now everybody has a subscriber channel
you know and everybody has their own
little Truman Show world you know so
there's something to be had there I I
often think and I'm asked about like
what what I think would have happened to
Truman when he goes outside the wall and
and it took me a while to realize that
basically he was alone out there too
because everybody went in back inside
they all wanted to be in the dome I'm
hey anything you know I'd love to see it
yeah thank you so much for talking to me
thank you